بالعكازات هذه لا غير يتسابقان الى حيث
يلعب الاطفال لكنهما يعودان الى المنزل
خائبين دون ان تلامس الكره القدم احدهم
على هذا الحال يوميا وبوجه تملاه الحسره
يتجرع الطفل بدر وشقيقه قسوه الحياه منذ
ان بترت قدم بدر حوثي بعثه في حي المطار
القديم غربي المدينه
[موسيقى]
ولا اكتب ولا قرين
اقسم اقسم
[موسيقى]
اليمنيه التي تسكن الحيه
ايش بتقول بعطاش
بكل حاجه بمعنى
فاقرع بسبب الحوثي انا هربت ابو من هناك
من هذا الاقيهم بعدين ولهناء يضربون قذائف
ومجاز عن طريق ما يشوفونها كثير من
الاطفال يعني
الغارات الجويه تماما وتوقف فيها المعارك
لكن استمرت جماعه الحوثي بالسيداء في
المدنيين والاطفال بشكل خاص الاطفال
النساء بالقذائف وهو عبد السلاح القناصه
عبر زراعه الالغام بكثير من المديريه في
تعز او كثير من المحافظات اليمنيه
مارسه الميليشات الحوتيه انتهاكات الجسيمه
بحق الاطفال التجول احصائيه الى ان اكثر
من 250 طفل في تعز يعانون من الاعاقه
نتيجه الحرب الحوثيه غالبيتهم لا يزالون
يخضعون لجلسات علاج طبيعي في مركز الاطراف
الصناعيه بمستشفى الثوره بتاعي عز
الحوثيه ان تجعل الكثير من ابناء المدينه
هذه يعيشون في اعاقه دائما خصوصا الاطفال
والنساء الذين تستهدفهم الى الاحياء
السكنيه والطرقات بالقضاء في والغام
الارضيه ال سعيد العربيه تعز